INTRO:
By now, I’m sure you’ve all heard about
the new iPhone 14.
It’s basically identical to the iPhone 13
even including the internal chip.
One thing that Apple should get credit for
is keeping the prices the same atleast for
American customers despite the record high
inflation.
The same, however, cannot be said about European
customers who experienced price hikes across
the board.
Take the iPhone 14 Pro Max for example.
In the US, this phone comes in at $1,100.
In the UK, this phone comes in at £1,199
and in Germany, this phone comes in at €1,449.
This translates to $1,385 in the UK and an
eyewatering $1,450 in Germany.
It wasn’t just the pro series that saw these
price bumps either.
All the standard iPhone models went up by
£70 or €100.
This means that the average European will
need to spend 30% more than an American to
get the same product.
Most people have written this off as pure
greed from Apple.
If Apple had risen prices in the US, the media
would’ve shredded them.
But, by only increasing prices in Europe,
they’ve been able to substantially reduce
the backlash.
This argument definitely has a lot of merit
to it given that Apple didn’t exactly need
to raise prices given their healthy profit
margins.
But, with that being said, there is also a
legitimate reason for raising prices only
in Europe.
To put it bluntly, European currencies are
currently performing a cliff dive maneuver
in comparison to the US dollar.
The conversion rate from Euros to Dollars
is at 20 year lows, and this isn’t some
new phenomenon either.
In fact, the Euro has been consistently losing
dominance to the dollar since mid 2008 when
you could get $1.60 using just €1.
Today, however, you can barely get a single
dollar with a single Euro.
A similar story can be seen with the pound
as well.
The pound is currently at a 37 year low against
the dollar and it has been on a consistent
decline since late 2007.
At the peak, you could get over $2 with a
single pound, but today, you can only get
$1.15 with a single pound.
When you consider these shifts in currency
values, Apple’s price hikes while still
insane, make a little bit more sense.
But, this brings up the question, why in the
world are European currencies doing so bad?
DEAD WEIGHT:
Taking a look back, this is clearly not a
new trend.
This downtrend has been forming for well over
a decade and the recent issues have simply
worsened the situation.
So, what set off this chain of events?
Well, one of the biggest fundamental issues
plaguing the Euro since its creation is the
fact that it’s not just representative of
one country.
Initially, this was seen as a benefit.
The Euro promised to unify the Eurozone countries
economically and make trade between these
neighboring countries easier than ever before.
This unification also promised to make Europe
as a whole a stronger economic force against
the US.
But, the problem with a unified currency is
that its virtually impossible to set economic
policies that are appropriate for every member.
You see, with America, while the various states
have differences culturally and politically,
they’re extremely homogenous economically.
When Californian businesses are suffering
from a bear market, so are Texan businesses.
Similarly, when New York businesses are booming,
it’s more than likely that Floridian businesses
are also booming.
So, it makes sense for all these states to
use the same currency and for the Fed to set
overarching economic policies.
The same, however, cannot be said about the
members of the Eurozone, and especially the
poorly performing members.
Over the past 15 years, this has primarily
been Spain and Greece.
You see, Greece basically got wiped out by
the 2008 financial crisis.
If the EU didn’t bail them out, Greece would’ve
defaulted on their debt and spiraled into
a depression.
During the worst of it, Greece’s budget
deficit was equivalent to 12.9% of their GDP.
For perspective, that would be equivalent
to the US have a budget deficient of $2.7
trillion per year.
At first, Greece tried to play it cool and
assured everyone that they would get their
debt in check within 2 years.
But, just 4 months later, Greece would admit
that could default at any moment.
Around the same time, Spain was going through
their own economic crisis.
Like Greece, Spain’s economy was devastated
by the 2008 financial crisis and they were
spiraling into a depression.
As an outside observer, Americans could feel
bad these countries and their people, but
economically speaking they weren’t all that
affected.
The same, however, could not be said about
Eurozone countries who had skin in the game.
Greece and Spain were already massive deadweights
bringing down the Euro, but if these countries
collapsed, oh boy, it would be bad.
So, the prosperous Eurozone countries had
no choice but to bail out these failing economies.
The EU and the IMF would provide 240 billion
euros worth of emergency funds to greece and
a 100 billion euro rescue package to Spain.
And where do you think all this money came
from?
It of course came from quantitative easing
also known as money printing.
Since 2008, the Euro money supply has literally
doubled.
To make things worse, the bailouts weren’t
all that impactful either.
Sure, they helped these countries stay afloat
and not default, but fundamentally, they didn’t
change anything, and the underlying economies
would just continue to get worse.
A BREAKING POINT:
While Spain and Greece were undergoing economic
hell, many EU countries like the UK and Germany
were actually recovering extraordinarily well.
They’re unemployment graphs were plummeting
and their need for money printing was dwindling.
However, they couldn’t stop the money printing
because certain Eurozone countries like Spain
and Greece were still very much feeling the
pain.
In both Spain and Greece, unemployment woud
rocket to 25 to 30%.
For perspective, unemployment didn’t cross
25% even during the worst of the great depression.
So, these countries were no longer just experiencing
a financial crisis.
They were in a full fledged economic depression
and this was painfully evident in their GDP
numbers.
Spain’s GDP would fall from a peak of $1.6
trillion to just under $1.2 trillion.
Similarly, Greece’s GDP would fall from
a peak of $354 billion to $192 billion.
Even today, neither of these countries have
been able to return to their peak GDPs.
And this becomes even worse when you consider
that Europe has been experiencing record inflation
meaning that their inflation adjusted GDPs
are even worse.
Also, while I’ve mainly been picking on
Greece and Spain throughout this video, these
guys were by no means the only perpetrators,
though they were the worst.
Some of the other countries dragging down
the Euro included Cyprus, Portugal, Italy,
Slovakia, and even France.
And this left the ECB in an extremely difficult
situation.
What were they supposed to do?
On one side, they have countries like the
UK, Germany, and Denmark were unemployment
was reaching historically low levels.
These countries indicated that it was time
to chill out on the money printing and potentially
even start quantitative tightening.
However, on the other end of the spectrum,
you had the perpetrators who were in a more
dire state than ever.
These countries indicated that it might even
be time to pump up the money printing.
The ECB would end up siding with the countries
that needed help and they would keep economic
policies loose.
While this was probably a godsend for the
struggling countries, the prosperous countries
weren’t exactly happy and rightfully so.
The prosperous countries didn’t really benefit
all that much from the loose economic policies,
but they were very much harmed by its accompanying
side effects.
They were starting to feel that they brought
significantly more to the table than they
were receiving, and this feeling is what would
eventually evolve into Brexit.
In June of 2016, Britain would vote on leaving
the EU, and after years of negotiations and
discussions, Brexit would finally take place
on January 31, 2020.
Much of England felt like they had finally
gotten a fresh start and that they were no
longer weighed down by the EU.
But, little did they know, the pandemic was
just around the corner.
FUEL TO THE FIRE:
Starting off with the most obvious economic
side effect of the pandemic, we have the money
printing.
People often like to criticize the US for
their excessive money printing as they should,
but what people often forget is that the whole
world has been printing just as much money
if not even more.
Take the UK for example who has printed £895
billion.
At the average conversion rate over the past
2 years, this is equivalent to $1.14 trillion.
Now, the US has grown its money supply by
a far larger amount coming it at roughly $6.2
trillion, but you have to look at it in relative
terms.
Compared to the American GDP of $21 trillion,
American printing works out to roughly 30%
of their GDP.
Compared to the English GDP of $2.7 trillion,
however, English printing works out to 42%
of their GDP.
The ECB hasn’t been nearly as aggressive
with their money printing, but they’ve been
much more lenient when it comes to interest
rates.
The ECB literally maintained negative interest
rates into 2022, and they’re just now starting
to aggressively hike rates.
All of that extra relative printing from the
UK and loose economic policies from the ECB
have to be reflected somewhere, and that somewhere
seems to be the conversion rates.
Economic policies aren’t the only battle
that Europe has been fighting though.
They’ve also been hit hard by Russian sanctions.
You see, Europe has historically been extremely
dependent on Russia for oil and natural gas.
Now that the west has decided to sanction
off Russia, Europe has been forced to find
new energy partners which has been anything
but easy.
The problem is that the entire world knows
that Europe is desperate for energy which
means that sellers can charge a premium and
that’s exactly what they’ve been doing.
Gas prices across the notable European countries
are well above $5 per gallon if not over $6
per gallon.
A similar story can be seen with electricity
prices as well.
Meanwhile, Russia is simply adding fuel to
the fire by essentially retaliating against
the sanctions.
You see, Europe has yet to fully cut off Russia.
They still receive a significant amount of
crude oil through pipelines like the Nord
Stream 1.
This specific pipeline was closed in July
for 10 days for regular maintenance.
But, when the pipeline was reopened, it was
only operating at 20% capacity.
Russia would close down the pipeline again
at the end of August citing an apparent leak,
and it has yet to be reopened as of September
8.
In reality, it seems like Russia is simply
halting oil flow on purpose to spike energy
prices in Europe.
As Europeans are forced to spend more on energy,
they’re naturally gonna pull back on discretionary
spending.
And given that the central banks are also
starting to pull back, this sets up the perfect
storm for an economic disaster.
THE STATE OF EUROPE:
At the end of the day, the Euro was created
with good intentions.
It aimed to unify Europe economically and
create a global powerhouse.
However, a major shortfall of the system is
the vast inequality between the member countries.
This has forced the prosperous countries to
constantly prop up the failing countries which
hasn’t been particularly helpful for either
of them.
The UK has decided to take this issue into
their own hands and become the first country
to leave the EU, but this hasn’t worked
out all that well either.
The pandemic along with the russian sanctions
have taken a massive toll on all European
countries, and most of them are simply fighting
to put off a nasty recession bring down inflation.
Compared to this, the US is actually doing
really well.
We’ve been ahead of the curve when it comes
to economic tightening and the recession isn’t
that bad, atleast not yet.
So, naturally, the US dollar has been destroying
European currencies, and by the looks of it,
that’s not gonna to be stopping anytime
soon.
So, Europe better get used to those iPhone
price hikes because they’re likely permanent,
but that’s just what I think.
What do you think about European iPhone prices?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you hope Europe can turn
things around.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.